nicht so
[Musik]
steinbrück
reil steht auf second hand läden und
fade nägel ihre devise gleichstellung
bedeutet nicht gleichmacherei serena
verabscheut frauen witze liebt
wassermelonen 700 ober und will frauen
in ihrer identität stärken
67 ab zuckerwatte und philosophie ihr
traum
michelle obama als präsidentin und das
ist ihr baby fand popp
so heißt das von ihnen gegründete online
magazin feminismus trifft pop darum geht
es ich will wissen was taugt dieser
hashtag aktivismus die neuen
feministinnen sehen eindeutig besser aus
aber kommt da noch was oder war es das
schon dass ich normen und stereotype
nicht ausdrücklich sagt befolge von den
er ohne sprache oder in der folge dass
ich meine weiblichkeit desolate wenigste
team ich definiere mich nicht vor
stimmenverlusten moment auf der welt
[Musik]
da ich es
was ist denn eigentlich neu am neuen
feminismus das will ich hier
herausfinden
kaum angekommen sehe ich etwas was ich
in dieser wohnung so gar nicht erwartet
hätte
[Musik]
ich will mich auch nicht völlig der
völlige unmöglichkeit mehreren stellen
durch mehrere projekte schöne
männerkörper und als ist als durch jede
menge humor das muster aufgestellt hat
styling und feminismus auch das scheint
neuerdings zu passen
die frauen sind mitten in der anprobe
für das bevorstehende shooting der neuen
online ausgabe wenn die so genannten
birkenstock feministinnen noch
achselhaare und praktisch solide
klamotten trugen ist feminismus jetzt
auch fanny nichts muss alles kann sexy
geht auch was hat dann eigentlich
fashion mit feminismus du musst halt
lich mit kleidung
und ich glaube es in bezug auf die
minister darum dass man in erster linie
das auto gefällt und wo man ohne
schwindel nicht dass man eben typisch
arbeitet als einmal aufbruch das ganze
wirkt er wie ein ausflug unter frauen
und nicht wie die reise in eine neue
weibliche zukunft
aber wenn das engagement in sachen frau
nicht nur kampf ist sondern auch spaß
macht lebenslust statt wut muss das dann
falsch sein
eine kurze autofahrt später treffen wir
in diesem türkischen lebensmittelladen
ein von frauen für frauen sowohl die
fotografen als auch die models machen
aus überzeugung mit für die macherinnen
sind solche produktionen noch neuland
nacht lang in helle auf der homepage in
der neuen online ausgabe geht es um den
orient und in feminismus in arabischen
ländern
warum trotz thema orient marokko
menschlich als auch nicht fragt der
minister muss es nicht das thema
ein modeaccessoire sticht mir sogleich
ins auge das kopftuch trendy
feministisch oder symbol patriarchaler
unterdrückung es geht verstehen muss
sich stark auf hochtouren sprache und
das kopftuchverbot fordere hofft durch
support anderen geht's los amtliche
stellen als mister wie die stelle wurde
allen anträgen des kopftuchs optisch
absolut falsch und ich glaube das
bewiesen die jungen feministinnen
ostereier landwirt ganz viel verdiene es
geht werde ich mich dagegen entschieden
ob es die ganz viel wie oder tragen oder
mit stolz tragen wenn eine frau sich
entscheidet ich wette es oft durch
tragen muss ist natürlich ein konflikt
zwischen dem was nicht freiwillig tragen
und denn was freiwillig trage so viel
gleichberechtigung war noch nie wir
haben bundesrätinnen dürfen wählen
abtreiben studieren ein konto eröffnen
und auch außerhalb des haushalts
arbeiten dass frau überhaupt dafür
kämpfen musste absurd sind wir nun
angekommen oder muss es weitergehen
leipzig rüstet bis franzis gefühl es
brauchte neue feminismus nein glaube ich
nicht glauben was wir haben ist
eigentlich schon gut wir müssen mehr
leben habe ich das gar nicht groß über
leitern street ich mache ich bestimmt
geschäftlich oder privat oder mal
häuptlinge die who definiert über das
thema ist also ich würde für eine
gleichberechtigung seien auf alle fälle
dass frauen genauso viel verdienen für
gleiches arbeiten wie man unbedingt ich
weiß nicht wie es in der schweiz in
deutschland ist das ein problem hier
auch ja also das müsste man ändern der
modernen feminismus kommt nun also in
sneakers und auf high heels daher statt
ma an instagram account äußerlichkeiten
lied kommt es zur inneren überzeugung
warum wird man feministin liegt der
ursprung in der familie und ari sulander
so wie ruhig es sie eigentlich dass man
muss
roller bild hat das konservative die
rede war haben wir ja bei ihnen hinzu
ich werde jetzt da raus und man sieht
geht die verschafft und waren so ist das
teil ja nehme geschafft ja es spiel
weniger fragen sie also vor allem müsse
finanzielle drauf sind
er hat natürlich aus wenn er not als
geschafft wird weiterhin der lohn kriegt
jedem flagge bereich haben aarhus gott
wie vielleicht gewünscht dass man
partner danach nie mehr trifft und
meefisch macht erklärt rasche umbildung
gezählt das ist viel vom millimeter und
die frage wie man das sehr gern gemacht
bitteschön stoßen wir auf das vorbild
der eltern eine klassische
rollenverteilung von mann und frau
trotzdem hat reil den feminismus schon
früh geprobt
er hat gespielt dem es sehr spielerisch
immer aber es ist wie mit fink nun eine
reiseleiterin direktorin ein als der
schnee so stellt sie ins reisebüro wo
ich früher schon ein paar tage später
treffen wir uns wieder
hierbei sehr ähnlich wie bei reihe wurde
auch bei cécile und serena daheim das
traditionelle familienmodell gelebt erst
während des studiums haben sie sich mit
der frauenrechtsbewegung
auseinandergesetzt
dann aber richtig aktiv neu gestanden
weg vom verstaubten männer hassenden
image
gleich zwei mal die woche damit alles
passt
er bete auch der märz demo dafür kam ein
nachruf in der slogan sand ausschlag
gaben
das rad ist verändern sie müssen mir
bist alles braucht einfach alle und sich
als schlusssatz straffung feminismus
profitieren feminismus ausstellung oder
geschlossen wir ja auch unterschiedliche
lassen steht anlockt und wann es durch
magie drucken möchte der demo mit machen
wieso sie dann wenn er sich sogar fast
uns auch lesen liegt vor den eltern
feministin und ich verstehe das stück
wird will da was ich sind so extrem
sieht dass man sich halt glaube ich ganz
klar abgrenzen
[Musik]
der dichte struktur die zweite ausgabe
ihres online magazins ist frisch im netz
der look ist girlie und munter mit
klassischen frauen heftrubriken wie
fashion food & design
die site stories interviews und
reportagen haben aber immer einen
feministischen inhalt und grund tun
damit treffen die drei den nerv der zeit
girl power liegt voll im trend
braucht der feminismus wo ich meine das
ist das thema im moment mode
interessiert das meer liegt aber
vielleicht trotzdem meldet für das thema
und radio sieht es dann weniger bis
liszt weimar und macht es das gedanken
und denn wieder interessanter sich
überzeugt vom eigentlichen themen und
was ist eigentlich gold und nachdenken
ist er als chance das ist im moment so
mainstream ist feminist stimmt sie und
nicht auf null bis negativ und es ist
nicht zu leicht wenn man vergleicht was
pokal marine geschaffen da schon ein
großer diskussionspunkt oder dem absolut
bewusst wir sind gott letzte mal wieder
ein buch wenn es am schluss stimmig
wirklich aggressiv
um also das ist sehr junger
feministischer die feministin was ist
denn der vorwurf wie eben genau das mit
dem halter flach lösung für
kommerzialisiert und mit dem social
media und so soll
ich glaube weil ich deine zukunft und
eine führanlage verschließt altes stück
verloren
zeiten ändern sich was bedeutet das für
den man konkret ihrem mann seal ist seit
dem teenageralter mit dominique liiert
inhaber eines friseursalons und
teilhaber verschiedener gastrobetriebe
sie führen eine zeitgemäße partnerschaft
beide gehen zur arbeit und teilen sich
den haushalt gleichmäßig auf die nacht
zuvor heute sehr viel ihren 29
geburtstag
wir haben sich zu vertrauen
erstaunlich sind für die stadt endlich
sagt das aber ich glaube mit zunge mauer
ist eine mauer hatte ich mir schon im
verletzungen immer werde ich mit klammen
zogen also will ich finde das hau
unattraktiven immer eigentlich nicht vor
hotel mama denn also sie sich für mich
wirklich sehr unabhängig vom august für
wenig gleichmäßiges teilen von erwerbs-
und hausarbeit so leben die meisten
jungen paare bis zu dieser einen
entscheidenden frage wann die machen
schlimmste man versagt so ein dankeschön
frau geschrieben ja ja ja ich denke im
moment ist er noch im landkreis thema
was wir dann diese roma verteidigt wie
letztes jahr bin ich sage euch danke das
war schon so dass jede flexible punkte
noch ist die gleichmäßige
rollenverteilung zukunftsszenario die
mehrheit der mütter heute arbeitet
teilzeit und leistet den großteil der
familienarbeit haupternährer bleibt der
mann die pop feministinnen wollen nicht
einfach missstände aufzeigen sie wollen
alternativen bieten auf eine lockere
zuweilen witzige art
das ist ja dass man nicht jetzt komma
getrennt
ja und wir sind für fähig ist
[Musik]
das thema reden gegen bringt uns als
lila das erste tor festival der schweiz
für schwule lesbische bisexuelle
jugendliche auch das ist neu während die
vorgängerinnen ausschließlich für
frauenrechte kämpften setzten sich die
modernen feministinnen für die
gleichstellung aller 1
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erster offizieller so cool festival und
es ist so ist wieso die homo ehe in
deutschland statement gedacht
besonders positiv unterstützen das ist
mir das oft auch identifizieren
[Gelächter]
sie fordern ein miteinander einen
respektvollen umgang der alltag zeigt
sich vielerorts aber weniger romantisch
sexismus grenzüberschreitungen und
verbale belästigungen kennt praktisch
jede
[Musik]
und ich beschuldige keine machen
damit erhält feminismus ist nicht
überholt es braucht ihn weiterhin und es
braucht ihn neu frauenkampf ist zurzeit
aber wie lange noch
trends vergehen heute in morgen out der
kampf um frauenrechte aber ist nicht so
schnell vorbei
[Musik]
es ist so viel passiert sieht viel
passieren
ende führt was also tag dieser herr
staeck aktivismus
[Musik]
111 auf instagram ist es das was
letztendlich bleibt oder sind twitter
und co die mittel einer neuen
feministischen revolution anklicken und
raus in die welt
ob tweed oder transparent es braucht
eine idee
es braucht politischen inhalt und es
braucht die frauen dazu
[Musik]